Speaker 1: This you have to see. Trump's lawyers
are now moving on to the next step in the deranged
defense of Trump, which is the things Trump might
be charged with aren't really crimes. They're not
really serious. These are mundane things. I know.
I know. They started with there were no documents.
And if there were documents, they were planted
by the FBI. They moved on to it's Trump's right
to have that stuff there. And he declassified
them. But then the classification status wasn't
actually the issue and they've moved on to all
these different arguments and the latest one,
and this is beyond parody. The latest one is these
are not really crimes. This is mundane stuff.
Trump attorney Olina Haba appeared
yesterday on the Charlie Kirk show
and you have to see this to believe it.
She says, Look at this stuff. They're
investigating Trump for things like espionage.
It's so mundane. Now, I don't know about you,
but a former president being investigated for
espionage seems pretty serious to me. But this
is the new argument they're coming up with.
Speaker 2: And they say themselves in the
paper that they filed that this is under the
Presidential Records Act. So what they did was to
try and criminalize Donald Trump, as they always
do. They found these three mundane statutes,
espionage and the two others obstruction. And
they're trying to claim that there was some
sort of criminal activity. But their papers
say it's under the Presidential Records Act.
So your admission is the power that we've all
been saying he does have, that you can take a
picture of top secret documents, Charlie, and show
the world a label. But if they're declassified,
as he has the right to do that, he has the
right to have them, and he would was working
together with Nara, as we know, and that back
and forth could have been done at a table
as they had been doing for months prior.
Speaker 1: So there's about a dozen different lies
in there. The documents were not declassified, and
also their classification is not actually what's
at issue. And they were speaking with Trump,
but Trump and his lawyers did not provide back
the documents. The FBI was waiting. You know, it's
lies after lie after lie. But the idea that these
are just mundane statutes like espionage, I mean,
it's basically jaywalking, you know, it's just
something police can use if they want to mess with
people or something like that. It's stunning that
this is now where they are going. And by the way,
Olena Haba also now places herself at the crime
scene. Is she not aware of the Fifth Amendment
or just like, you know, shutting your mouth and
not saying things that could get you pulled in
to where you might now need a lawyer? Here is
Elina Harbor on Fox saying she has firsthand
knowledge. She was there in Trump's office.
Speaker 3: Again, nowhere what's happened is
now they've put this picture out so that you
would assume a name, somebody who has been in the
press loves to talk about this, especially today.
I'm somebody that has been in his office. I've
seen it. Oh, this is not the way his office looks.
They give you this appearance that you walk in
and there's these top secret documents just strewn
about strong. B, they don't understand. Something
could be mark, top secret could be marked
classified. The Presidential Records Act, he would
have said. This is declassified. It doesn't get a
new marking all the time. He's left the office.
Speaker 1: All right. So you get the point. And
again, the classification status of the documents
for most of the crimes Trump's being investigated
for is not actually what is at issue. Is this the
next Trump lawyer to potentially be disbarred? Is
this the next Trump lawyer to maybe need a lawyer?
Remember MAGA making attorneys get attorneys?
Unclear, but she doesn't have to implicate
herself as a material fact witness as so often
Donald Trump's lawyers end up being. It's really
something else. You can see all these clips if
you're just listening today and curious what some
of these people look like that we're hearing from.
You can find all of these clips on our Instagram.
Just Search for David Pakman show on Instagram.